Welcome back.
In this lecture, I'm going to talk
about the concept of coded photography.
Recall, again, the whole pipeline
of computational photography.
We have illuminated scene
that goes through a series of
different processes to be able to
capture the light to generate an image.
Now, one concept we looked at was,
how do we control different
aspects of this pipeline?
We looked at how to control light,
the illumination sources.
We also want to now start thinking about
how we can actually change things inside
a camera and the optics and such to be
able to generate newer forms of images.
This leads us to the concept
of coded photography.
We actually have looked at some of
these ideas briefly when we talked
about the concepts of
epsilon photography.
Epsilon photography was when we
basically said, let's take a series
of pictures of something,
just different in one parameter.
Now, actually,
let's talk about how we can create
those changes in the camera itself.
And the whole concept of coded
photography is basically being able to
put something in a camera that would
let us capture this information
right on the camera itself.
And all of the variations that come in,
perhaps,
on things like epsilon photography,
but done on-board on a camera.
We're going to talk about how to modify
cameras to support this in principle and
actually what you're learn about is,
again,
the whole principle of coded
photography through this lecture